to give us a talk on local codes uh she
received her P from MIT and is now an
assal thanks thanks thanks a
lot okay thanks Henry um and thanks
everyone for coming back from lunch um
um so I'll be talking about locality um
and the locality especially in coding
Theory and the goal of the talk is going
to be especially to uh build up
intuition into how people think about
locality um and uh um talk about what
has been done out there which is a lot
of work so I I won't be uh giving um I
won't be able to talk about everything
but um I'll talk about kind of like the
main directions um mention about some
recent breakthrough um in locality in
local um locality of codes and actually
the past few years have been quite
amazing in terms of breakthroughs we
have breakthroughs almost in everything
we care about um and uh and then I'll
I'll mention along the way some um open
problems um okay so feel free to
interrupt me um okay so locality is a
relatively uh modern notion uh in coding
uh and the modern means um kind of like
from the '90s um and it refers to the
setting where um the algorithm doesn't
get to see the entire data in this case
doesn't get to see the entire um uh code
word or the the entire received word uh
but it's allowed to interact with the
data via what we call queries so queries
um are essentially um um um indices into
the data we ask a query uh which means
like what is the value of the data at
position q1 um and we get back the value
uh and uh position Q2 and so on and so
forth um and uh the goal is to make as
few queries as possible and still be
able to solve uh interesting um coding
problems even though uh we might
encounter uh a lot of Errors so we have
a very sublinear uh view of the data uh
yet we want to be able to uh solve
interesting problems um and um okay so
so the um
important um parameter of the talk will
be the most important parameter will be
locality which is the number of
queries and uh the goal is to perform um
as few queries as possible so sublinear
in the length of the input um ideally
constantly many queries but as we'll see
even uh queries that are sublinear
in in the anywhere in this range are
going to be interesting uh regimes so
why do we care about uh locality U well
it's this is in the context of large
data little time um data is expensive um
expensive to access and because we
really can do lots of interesting things
with um just a local view of the
data okay
so uh so the the kind of things I'm
going to talk about today are going to
be locally testable codes decodable and
correctable codes um and some uh
variants um and uh and then local
locally recoverable or local
reconstruction codes uh in the last part
of the talk
um locally testable decodable and
correctable codes have had um plenty a
lot of applications uh throughout TCS um
I'm listing here a few um U but this is
not a comprehensive list and I'm I'm I'm
not listing all the papers that U are
doing great work uh on these
applications um I just wanted to uh to
emphasize that um I will be talking
about three error models hemming which
is the standard um error model that
we've seen in the past uh few days uh
here but I'll also be talking about
insertion and
deletions uh iner insertion and deltion
codes um and then um erasers so that's
in the context of distribution
storage
okay so let's start with locally
testable codes uh this is something that
you've already kind of got a glimpse of
um in in multiple talks this week um the
general plan will be the following I'm
going to talk about um what it means to
um for property I'm going to talk about
necessary conditions for testing um
which uh constraints and
characterizations are some uh I'm going
to talk about po pomal codes um I'm
going to look at tests for polinomial
codes a little bit more in detail um and
some analysis vignettes um and then um
about how to come up with uh new codes
from old ones new ltcs from uh old ones
via um things like symmetry lifting
tensoring um and this is all kind of to
um set up the stage for the the the big
breakthrough on a C3 ltcs that prad is
going to talk in detail uh
tomorrow
okay so um what is a locally testable
code um a locally testable code is um a
code that uh for which there exists an
algorithm that makes a few queries um
let's say l queries and is able to
distinguish between the the case when
the received word is in the code or far
from
it okay with high
probability um okay and these are um the
the acceptance probability uh these are
no standard notion of um
okay um uh completeness and soundness um
if the queries can be seen in advance
then the tester is non adaptive
otherwise it's called adaptive
um interestingly for linear codes it
turns out that um
any two-sided non-adaptive test uh can
be transformed into into a one-sided um
sorry two-sided adaptive test can be
transformed into a one-sided
non-adaptive test so non adaptivity and
and um uh two-sidedness it's um kind of
irrelevant for linear linear codes um
and uh there is a stronger version uh
which is
um the fact that the test not only uh
rejects when it's far from the code but
it rejects with some probability that is
proportional with the distance uh of the
received word from the code so this is a
stronger version and it turns out that
all the codes we're going to talk about
today including the C3 code um satisfy
the stronger
version okay
uh
so
um okay the the upshot
um the gold standard in local table
codes has been for a long time um
achieving codes that have constant
locality uh constant constant rate and
relative distance there is a question
sorry one side means perfect
completeness or perfect completeness
yeah
um exactly so we always accept when
we're seeing something from the code and
this is kind of important because it
builds up into um these Notions that are
coming up like
constraints okay so so uh this has been
the gold standard for a long time uh
it's now been resolved everybody talks
about uh this new result by the era uh
LEL laosi and Moses um and
um let me start with with with kind of
like the basics um so the
first um code that was proven to be
locally testable was um the hardart
code so the hardar code is just um the
set of vectors um where each um position
a is um the value at each position a is
the inner product of a and x uh where a
and X are um binary and variate uh
vectors uh and testing means given some
receive W output um yes if W is a Hmart
code word or reject if it is far from
theart uh
code okay where far means uh hemming
distance okay so here is the B basic
test uh the basic test picks you uh
picks A and B uniformly at random and it
simply checks uh this very succinct
property that W of a plus W of b equals
W of a plus b so it queries w at
position a b and a plus b and it just
verifies that this condition holds over
F2 okay so it's a very simple test it's
a very succinct test it makes three
queries um and why does it work well
completeness it turns out to be trivial
every linear code has this property so
we're always going to accept um
soundness is the the hard part um and
this this is kind of like how pretty
much every proof of testable codes uh
Works um in in like a at a very high
level um you go by proving the counter
positive so assume that uh the test um
accepts with high probability then w we
want to show that W is close to the code
okay so
um a very important step here that again
turns out to be the crucial step in most
of
the proofs for testability of codes uh
is this notion of self uh correction uh
which is
um which uh is the following so
um basically we're given W and we want
to uh show we want to
find a code word that is close to
W okay so now we're going to explicitly
Define that code word um as follows at
each position a I'm going to look at the
vote of B uh for a um as W of a plus B
minus W of B okay so each B comes up
with a
vote for the value at this position and
depending on the field that we're
working on we're going to take the
majority or the plurality uh over all
these
values okay so we do this for every a
and um what remains to be shown is that
whatever we obtained this CW is actually
something that is close to
W right we're close to the code um and
and that is a code word okay that it is
really a linear uh function in
particular here uh and this is the
harder part in all of the proofs showing
that this apparently unstructured
Vector actually has a lot of
structure so this is the kind of like
the magic of this blr proof is that it
really kind of sets the stage for um
strategies for proving
LTC um um throughout uh the entire um
field okay so the takeaway again um is
most proof um proofs rely on defining on
on the self-correcting
step where um we take a vote for um for
the value of the each position um and
and then proving that uh the
self-correction step gives us um
something that is close to the CT and
something that is uh um something that
is close to W and something that is in
the code okay so um there's going to be
a lot of hammers and
nails uh thanks to Mary she provided us
with a lot of uh with with this very
nice uh pictures uh but I think in might
talk they're going to appear at random
places so
don't don't take them too seriously um
okay so so local constraints this is a
necessary condition what what are these
uh so in in in the Hmart uh case we
looked at a and A+ B um these form a
local con constraint okay so these form
local constraints four linear codes um
they are three local in the sense of we
have only three things we're looking at
uh three U positions um and sometimes
people look at um at constraints the
constraint um set as um as um a graph a
bipart graph where on the left hand side
we have the the code word locations and
on the right hand side we have vertices
that represent constraints and we have
edges uh for uh between the constraint
um the nodes in in each
constraint
okay um so anyways dual codes we all
know um let me I just want to
say say something in two ways so that's
why I'm defining the Dual Cod it's just
the the Subspace dual to um the code C
for linear codes um and uh the
observation I want to make here is that
um for um every A and B for every
location for every Vector a and ve every
two vectors A and B uh the Dual of the
Hmart code contains a code word that is
supported on a b and a plus b which
means that um I have one ones in these
locations and zero everywhere
else okay so this this is a vector can
you imagine it's a vector where I only
have three one at location a b and a
plus b everywhere else we have a zero
okay so what I'm saying here is that
um the Dual contains uh kind of low
weight constraints um and just let me
get there uh in a bit uh so a canonical
tester for linear codes is simply to
pick a dual code word um and this is
again a result of um um B on har andot
nikova um and this implies that if we
want um L local testing we need to have
L local constraints constraints that are
supporting supported on at most W uh
sorry L many uh
locations okay so dual contains uh
coders of weight uh L and um the code
has um a local constraint okay so this
is a necessary condition for
testing um what else is testable okay we
have BL we have linear codes um the next
question people asked what else is
testable um and it turns out that pretty
much everything we care and love is
testable um so read Solomon read merer
dual bch a fining variant codes lifted
codes multiplicity codes we've seen
quite a few uh of uh these um
definitions so far so what I plan on
plan on doing next is to show a little
bit more um to look a little bit more at
the constraints or
characterizations um or or the tests the
tests that we have for each of these
family of codes so this is just to build
um more intuition of what people have
done and there is an enormous amount of
work
um in this area people care about
optimizing parameter soundness
um the soundness par parameter uh
degrees versus degrees versus field
sizes which is something that I'm not
really going to go into um but I just
want to kind of build up more intuition
about what what people um how people
test things um and I'll I'll I'll tell
you already the punchline um which is
it's all about restricting to a fine
subspaces okay so pretty much all the
tests we're going to see um are
restrictions to to aine
subspaces um including lines lines is an
aine Subspace and there is a hammer um
okay so read Solomon codes these are
evaluations of uh low deegree polinomial
over a field um um f let's just call it
f here of size n
um and um so the goal is can be
reformulated as uh given
f is f a low degree polinomial or it's
far from
it that's what testing means um and the
the tests are built on on something
called local characterizations which is
um characterizations uh that are
constraints uh that um kind of are
satisfied with an if and only if uh in
front of them okay so basically that
means uh here it means the following we
have the following
um um local characterization f is the
degree Deo if it satisfies if and only
if it satisfies um this type of a
constraint so this is a linear
combination of f uh when we evaluate F
over a
line okay so um I is from sorry I is
from0 to uh D +1
um and we have some coefficients AI
which are they they look like this it
doesn't matter there exist some
coefficients such that when you take
these linear combinations of f
restricted to this line we we get um
zero okay um So based on um uh this um
local characterization uh the test
simply restricts F to point on this line
and accept um uh if the constraint is
satisfied and otherwise it
reject just the a are different from the
at
beginning it's not how to choose oh yeah
sorry yeah they are different they're
different yeah they should be called
something else yeah these are the
evaluation
points and this is just a
coefficient call it
beta okay so but it's a very nice
property of uh of um low degree ping
nomials and it follows from taking
derivatives essentially taking the DS
plus one derivative um okay so how uh
what else need do we how do we Analyze
This Test
um the self correction step here uh is
is something like well look at um all
these evaluations and notice that when I
equals z we just get F
ofx right and use um the vote of the
remaining points on the line to kind of
like to vote for X right so pick a
random line vote for through X vote for
X using the values of the points on that
line and and do this for every single um
line okay so that's um the value that
we're going to set for p of X that's the
self correction step and we're going to
take a plur plurality over uh all these
values um and it turns out that because
this is a characterization I mean there
is work lot of work going on uh in in
proving this this is the hard step as I
mentioned before but this
characterization um implies that this P
of X that we obtain is actually um a
close by code word and it is a
code okay
so oh okay so just one so this test um
in terms of uh in terms of parameters um
the locality is D plus2 so we're looking
at D plus2 points here um rate is
something like d over n and distance is
uh n minus
d okay so if D is a constant then rate
is pretty
bad um let's look at
um The Next Step Up So read M codes when
we look at read M codes um
the degree versus the size of the uh
field or the characteristic of the field
um play a role so um the maybe the first
test for let's talk about Char
characteristic two um is
due to um Alan kman kich Len and Ron and
um we have a similar local
characterization here which says the
following so pick an a fine
Subspace through
X okay look at the value of F at every
single point on the Define Subspace sum
it up um and um it you should get a zero
okay so if you if you sum up the value
of f over um the Subspace of Dimension
plus one uh you should should get a zero
um and as you can imagine you can use
this characterization to get a vote
um okay um here we're going to take
majority because we're working over F2
um and uh um the upshot is a test with
locality two to the um two to the L uh
sorry two to the D where D was the
degree uh but um when D is a constant
then this is a constant uh degree uh
constant locality test and this is also
tight because um because of red merer um
uh because of the distance of red M
codes so we cannot have shorter
constraints in the
door
okay um okay so there's another Hammer
um um what about larger characteristic
uh
Fields uh we have this General local
characterization which we've heard a
couple of times um if we res uh restrict
F so in general uh we're looking at
degree d polinomial uh in M variables
over some field f um this time the field
U the field size is larger than the
degree um and um
the local characterization that is used
for testing is uh that f is a degree D
polinomial if and only if restricted to
um a f sub spaces through x uh is uh a
degree at most the
polinomial and based on um this sort of
characterization um people have come up
with many many many tests this has been
beaten up to death this technique has
been beaten up to death um some of the
the test that people um study a lot um
is restrict to a random line okay um
find a low degree polinomial find a univ
polinomial on the line as we talked a
couple of times about um this test in
previous lectures um interpolate pick a
and pick a random point and check
consistency okay so this is called the
line Point test it's been
um studied again and again and I just
noticed there is a recent paper by uh
prad and cars um that kind of gets the
best um parameters for this test best
the ti tight analysis for this test so
it's a very recent uh
result so another kind of a test is pick
a two dimensional aine sub
space um and then pick a random point
and check for consistency this is called
a plane Point uh test um and another uh
test is pick two two dimensional fine
sub spaces that intersect on a line um
check
consistency um on the entire line and um
um accept only when we have agreement on
the entire line so this
is um kind of a
it's a test or the High um kind of like
the conceptual contribution of this test
due to Raz and Safra um is
that the tests themselves um have quite
a bit of
agreement okay so there is agreement
between the tests and somehow this local
agreement will kind of propagate up into
Global agreement so this is kind of like
a crucial um notion uh that eventually
even plays a role uh in the it's a
powerful technique and it plays plays a
role um conceptually I'm just saying uh
in the the C3 LTC
result okay
so there are all the tests like is there
any trade-off like why all of yeah there
are trade-offs there are many trade-offs
between uh between query
complexity um soundness D
versus the degree versus the field size
um robustness which is actually
something I'm going to Define next yeah
there are many
trade-offs um and yeah you can Define
read M codes
over various fields and
um like Prime fields or fields of the
form P to the Q and kind of like there
are variants
for for for many many settings um so
another notion of testing um is that of
robust testing um and again this is a a
notion that will that is Satisfied by
all the tests that people have cared
about so far or most of the test or the
test that we're talking about uh uh in
this uh lecture um and this notion
refers to the fact that um if f is far
from the
code um when we take um a local view not
only we realize that the local view is
not what it should be so we we should
just reject but the local view is
actually far from it what it should
be okay so um more um kind of precisely
um we want to reject kind of
emphatically if f is far from the code
so uh if f is far from the code then the
projection onto whatever set we're
projecting on to is far from um kind of
the code that should be C projected to S
um so the expected distance between F
and S and uh C restricted to S is at
least some Alpha which is a constant
uh times the distance from the code okay
so this is a stronger notion of testing
um for instance for read merer codes um
so usually
um robust testing comes at the price at
the price of more queries um
so one result about uh read M codes is
that they are robustly testable
for you Square many uh queries um and
any Alpha greater than one when U when
the degree bound is um almost as good as
um the field size um anyways I'm not
going to D I'm just uh my goal here is
to just tell you Notions that people
care about um I'm not and and the reason
why this notion is uh going to be
important is because of um kind of
recursive testing when we want to to
test a big code by projecting into um
coordinates that should look like
smaller codes
um if the smaller code is a locally test
testable code and the code itself is
robust with respect to these projections
then the big code is going to be locally
testable with a little bit of a loss in
soundness uh but but this is a robust
testing is also crucial um
um um notion of testing used in PCP and
uh anywhere where we need to kind of um
recursively test Elena when you have o q
is that relative to M getting large
while T stays
fixed
um what's what's
growing so D is growing so D so this
this kind of results were initially
known for kind of small D like uh Q over
two about Q over two um so I'm
embarrassed but I I forgot to put a
reference for for for this result um so
um so this the big deal about this is
that it works for uh even D that goes up
to to the field size um and
uh and I think Alpha is actually a
function of d
so yeah D is growing and Alpha is a
function of
D
okay okay so all the codes in this talks
are robustly testable but that's pretty
much what I'm going to say about robust
testing um so let me quickly summarize
what we've learned so far and then we're
going to move on to um other Notions of
test uh other codes that are testable so
we we've learned that local
characterizations are um a fine
subspaces so they usually have a lot of
structure we care about structure uh
when uh testing um local
constraints
um have or should have large pairwise
agreements uh that kind of leads uh that
kind of plays into the Paradigm that
local structure uh um kind of creates
Global structure or local agreement
creates global
agreement
um and robust testing is useful in
composing tests uh and uh it turns out
that all these ingredients um are
important uh in the C3 uh LTC
result okay so do we have any questions
while I'm going to
some
okay so what else is testable
um uh there is this kind of
um um direction of research where people
that that was started with cman and the
Sudan where um people wanted to
characterize what exactly leads to
testability okay so do we have necessary
and sufficient conditions for
testability uh so this is kind of a
direction that is
um slightly disjoined but also connected
to that of finding best parameters for
tability um but here we're asking um
what makes a property
testable okay so in particular um conf
and Sudan notied that all the properties
we looked at have this uh property that
they're a fining variance so which means
that
um
which I mean the following so um a
function um a code uh C is invariant
under a permutation Pi of the domain of
f um if F in C implies that F composed
to Pi also belongs to the
code okay so in particular a finding
variance means that uh F in C um implies
F of a X plus b also uh belongs to C uh
for all a fine
Maps um take X to
X okay uh so in particular if we look at
the the the read M code on um let's say
m variables um any fine transformation
of the variables is going to still then
do into the code the
de okay so one other observation we can
make here is that just also kind of in
order to build some orientation is that
if C is a fining variant um and we have
a constraint of r k let's say then um if
you take a the every um element of the
constraint and permut it or um permuted
using um the uh fine map um we're also
going to end up with a constraint so
finding variance plus one constraint it
will lead us to more
constraints okay so that's kind of nice
um and there is an even stronger notion
that uh which is called single orbit
characterization which says that
essentially one
constraint determines the code in the
sense of f belongs to see if and only if
for all a fine Maps um a um f opposed to
a also satisfies s and I should have
said
that s is a local constraint for C okay
so if we have one local constraint s the
code and the code is a fining variant um
and if it is if f is in the code if and
only if it f go to a satisfies this
constraint um then we have this property
called L single orbit characterization
and this is a very nice property because
um it implies that the code is testable
and locally testable so uh this is a big
theorem of kman and Sudan which
essentially unifies the testability of
everything that um that we've known uh
we've seen so far um and um and even
more okay uh and I'm going to say a
little bit a little bit more about even
more so because because all these codes
do have this property single
characterization so one can prove that
all these codes are actually
characterized by one single
constraint okay
um so one might ask um what do binary
fine invariant codes look like um and
I'll say a few words about um what uh
about this so in
particular um if C is a code let's talk
about binary codes that apply um F2 to
the N the field F2 to the N into F2 so
The Big Field into the small field um is
a fine invariant if and only if it can
be described by a collection of degrees
B uh in the following sense that c is
exactly the set of polinomial of the
form trace of P ofx where the degrees in
P of X belongs belong to uh this
particular
okay are people following or have I lost
so there is a so with each a find
invariant code you can um um associate a
set of degrees and those are the only
degrees that you can see uh inside uh
the trace function okay so I think I
know why people might have been Rost
because the trace function uh is this
function here um it Maps F2 to the N
into F2 right so it maps The Big Field
into the small field um and it it really
just looks like this it has very nice
properties um like it's a linear
function trace of X Plus of yal of X
Plus y
um
um raising the trace of something to the
power two to the I yes um just to CL we
say like the code words are trace of PX
those would those be like the
then I guess the code words evaluations
so the code words are yeah I'm thinking
of evaluations of
traces evaluation tra yeah all point2
yeah
um okay now p is a polom with
coefficients in F to it's coefficients
in F2 to the N here we can play whatever
we want we're going to end up in F2 to
the end but we're going to be mapped
down to F2 by the trace function and
then is set D arbitrary set or is it
like up to some number um it's a set of
degrees up to 2 to the N minus
one is it contigous or is it like some
so it with with each a fine invariant
property you can associate a set D but
you do need some properties it's not
it's not so actually I'm going to say
next uh read M of order two for instance
can be viewed as a univ
polinomial where the set of degrees have
weight binary weight to so they only
look like 2 to the I plus to the
J um rer of order W
is um all s of degrees that have binary
weight
w okay dual bch um D is bounded I'm I'm
I'm lying a little bit here but
essentially um the um
um set of degree
um there are some equivalence classes
and the um set of degrees uh that we
care about uh is um founded um then
sparse
codes are a finding variant codes for
which the set of degrees is small so
it's a generalization of dual bch they
don't have to be up to T but they there
is there is a small size set that
describes the degrees okay so this uh I
I have some conjectures here this is
something I worked on during my uh PhD
and broke my heart uh so I'll just
quickly mention them um uh
so we want necessary in condition for a
family of course to be a fin in variant
um and the conjecture is that a binary
aining variant code when n is prime um
is um testable if and only if it's
either read M or a sparse
code okay so it's it's a very simple to
State
conjecture um we know that these are
testable so we know One
Direction um and in general finding
variants invariant codes are testable if
and only if they can be obtained from
red merer and sparse codes via some
operations um addition intersection or
lifting which is something I'm going to
talk about
next
okay uh
so how do we obtain new codes from old
ones new codes from lifting we have a
base code uh we've already seen this I'm
going to quickly go over uh this
definition we have a base code um B um
and the lift of B is the set of all
functions um and I can add as many um
variables as I want such that the
Restriction of
f to um every single line belongs to to
the
Cod yes just on the previous slide you
talking only about binary codes but it's
there General sum statement so this is
for the non-binary this is the general
statement okay but the but the statement
about about you know if it's the trace
that can be as this Trace could I have a
similar statement just over
like fine fields
or um yeah I mean even in general you
can uh okay so how do you get the
degrees um you have to be more
careful but yeah so one property of the
degrees is that um they are closed under
kind of
removing um to the ey Powers um so there
are some properties of the set of
degrees that you can use uh so I need to
remember what happens for General field
um
but um yeah once you take PL plus is
easy uh lifts is what can mess up things
and I'm not sure if one can characterize
precisely what the how
the um but yeah we can talk
yeah
okay um so restrictions to every line
keeps you in the code uh and more
generally um restrictions to any three
dimensional Subspace uh keeps you in the
code okay wow I think
I'm yes uh I had a question about the
projector in the previous
slide regarding the first conjecture is
it true say like 2 to the N minus one
prime
[Music]
um I don't think we we know some
things um but no I don't think it's I
don't think it's
know um yeah it's we know some things
but we're and actually it can be
described I can talk offline about about
this but um yeah anyways let's let's
move on because I realized that I've
been really slow um okay so lifting you
can also Define lifting by using
restrictions to three dimensional
subspaces lifting gives new families of
codes um in particular lifts of read
merer and uh gives you possibly not
things um and the upshot is that gu
Karan Sudan um created uh new families
of testable codes with localities of
this in this uh regime and to the
Epsilon uh and high rate uh constant
distance um using um lifts which was the
first time such a result uh was uh
obtained um and
uh and then similar ranges of parameters
um have been um obtained even
afterward
um where
so so tensoring which is something that
Mary talked about last time uh and I'm
I'm actually going to go very quickly
over this restrictions to lines don't
work um but uh kind of the nicest test
here is projections to two dimensional
spaces so if you want to test um tensors
of M uh versions of B U pro projections
to two dimensional spaces uh works out
um multiplicity codes this is exactly
what prad talked about earlier so I'm
going to
skip uh so in terms of State ofthe art
before C3 we have um constant um
locality um ltcs with rate one over
polylog these are the PCP type
constructions um and then the results we
saw before um and actually the last one
here is a a
by party mayor Ron and zie and saraf um
is um it's kind of a very intriguing
result because um people didn't expect
to get to locality and to the L of1
actually all these tests have lower
bounds of ENT to the Epsilon um so uh
this this is uh this was a a huge
surprise um and these are codes that um
um that were obtained via the alone lby
transform which again Mar that so
anyways um after so this is kind of like
the
classical work on uh locally testable
codes in the past 10 years there has
been a lot of work um of local
testability from the perspective of high
dimensional expanders um these are kind
of high di menal versions of uh ldpc
codes or tener codes um
and
um it turns out that ldpc codes are
actually not
testable um
but
um but uh somehow they they
um um some versions of ldpc eventually
uh can be built into a testable uh code
but the interesting thing I wanted to
say here is that um all the tests that
I've been telling you about these
projections to aine sub spaces um can be
explained from the perspective of high
dimensional um random walks in high
dimensional Gras Manan uh complexes
which are kind of like um um
multipartite graphs where each part um
contains U let say on one side points on
another side planes on another side
cubes and the edges represent the
inclusion so the test that we've looked
at uh there is an explicit link between
uh something called agreement expanders
and uh all these uh test testing results
that we've
seen okay so anyways uh this is just uh
putting everything together in one
slide um the the C3 LTC code this is a
kind of a teaser for the talk of prod
tomorrow uh it's a and actually we've
seen Nick's talk earlier today uh the
code is a lift of a product code for
some very special um C Prime and couble
Prime um the test is pick a random
constraint um and test if we see a code
word uh in C Prime uh times C Prime and
the keywords here robustness constraints
have many agreements expander graphs um
cell correction um um are all kind of
keywords in into
the the proof that we're going to see
tomorrow and see the proof tomorrow um
okay so uh I think I I took way too much
time for this part of the talk let's
move on into locally decodable codes and
uh relatives um so I want to talk about
some state-of the results some proof
strategy strategies for for the lower
bound uh wanted to build up a little bit
into the Breakthrough results the new
lower bounds that came out last year um
and some relatives and then in the next
lecture I'll talk about insertion
deltion locally decodable okay so
locally decodable codes these are codes
for which we want to decode each bit of
the message very quickly so we want to
make a few queries into the received
word and be able to uh decode for each
bit of the message um the value XI by
just making a few okay
so um we want to decode the probability
at least half plus Epsilon um and I'm
going to not stare at the definition too
much longer um but
again a standard example of a two query
Lo decodable code um code is the hadamar
code the previous uh property that we we
saw again gives us a two query locally
decodable code
um there is um a related notion locally
correctable codes uh these are codes for
which uh I'm even removing the message
we want to be able to quickly recover
each bit of the encoding itself the code
word so the code word bit I we want to
recover it with probability that this
half plus Epsilon um and again the Hadar
code as you would expect is uh to query
locally correctable code uh and just a
quick observation here uh linear locally
correctable codes um are actually
locally decodable codes because they are
systematic so the message bits are
um appear in the uh Cod okay
so locally decodable codes from Hadar
from read merer codes um
guess what the same uh restriction to
lines gives us um um a local decoder for
r m codes and uh if you play with the
parameters this is the kind of
trade-offs you get you get uh for
locality constant we get exponential uh
length
ldcs um for locality that looks like
poly log n uh we get all almost linear
codes um and locality that is about the
epon we get
um Conant rate codes where the depends
on
EP uh and the state of the art in the
other
regimes um is uh so we have a lower
Bound for two queries what we saw the
Hmart code is the best you can do for
two
queries uh for three
queries um there was a breakthrough
result of yonin um and uh with followup
works by many others uh that gave a
subexponential length uh locally
decodable ca for three queries and here
the lower bound till very recently was
just N
squared okay and uh the the the
remaining regime is exactly what
happened uh the same kind of trade-offs
that we have for local
for some reason um so let me quickly say
a few words
about um lower bounds
so the uh kind of upshot here what
everybody studies is a particular um so
one can show that for each message bit I
we can associate a hyper graph where the
vertices of the hyper graph are are the
um uh the uh um elements of the code
word um and um each hyper Edge contains
what uh the a q query okay so the
queries that the local decoder should
make you can create a hyper Edge um out
of let's say a particular Q query that
the decoder makes um and this hyper um
Hy graph this Q uniform hyper graph
turns out to have a large uh matching in
the sense of um a large number of edges
that do not intersect so the
queries uh the toles of queries do not
intersect so uh in particular there
exists a large matching of size let's
say when Q is a constant
linear okay so for each ey uh we have
such a hyper with a large matching and
the remaining proofs for lower bounds
essentially Analyze This matching
um just uh a few words about this uh new
breakthrough uh result of um Arabian
guruswami
katarian monohar from U last year so uh
for the first time they break the and
the K squar barrier and an uh K uh K
Cube Omega K Cube lower bound um so this
is an amazing result it's been um more
than I don't know 15 years that we've
seen um an improvement on the lower
bound um and just a few words about the
proof uh so the proof
makes um kind of views the
um so first of all the the um the
queries that the decoder makes you can
write down a system of
equations uh with one equation per um
couple of queries so for instance here
I'm color coding the hyper graph let's
say for message uh bit one and uh we're
looking at three queries so X1 X4 X6 uh
formal query X2 X3 X10 formal query uh 5
S9 formal query um and we can write this
linear system of equations uh for um
that that um is supposed to have a
solution uh that um satisfies at least
half L Epsilon of these equations so one
can view this system as a constraint
satisfaction problem and uh um here the
strategy
uh
is uh to show a low bound is to find
What's called the refutation
algorithm uh to the system having um a
large
value value half plus Epsilon um and um
of course they do a lot of work and
they they build on result results on
semi random CSP reputations that um that
some of
some some very recent results and some
um um breakthrough from a few years ago
so anyways this is just kind of like the
starting point of their proof um and
then a subset of the authors get kind of
like your dream lower bound and
exponential lower Bound for not ldcs but
for lccs linear lccs uh so three query
linear lccs must have exponential
uh length so this is again a fantastic
result it's all you can expect um for um
so essentially this gives us solves the
problem for uh three query
lccs um it matches the r m linear lccs
it matches the uh red merer upper bound
up to polyk factors um and it also shows
a strong separation between locally
correctable and locally decodable code
which is something we didn't know um so
the constructions of yanan are not
locally correctable um and of course I
mean there there are open problems to
extend uh that's going to be really hard
open problems but we want to uh extend
to any uh locally decodable
code um or improve the upper bound and
also extend to non
nonlinear
um I think I'm out of time or do I
I have five minutes
or yeah so I think um five minutes is
five minutes okay so just very quickly
there is a variant called relax locally
decodable code uh and in this variant
the decoder is allowed to say I don't
know it's it's allowed to fail um so
it's allowed to fail but it's not
allowed to fail by too much so for each
message bit it should respond uh the
correct with the correct bit or I don't
know with probability half plus Epsilon
and it should actually respond with the
correct bit for a long a large fraction
of message okay so it turns out that
these three properties are actually the
third property is not um implied by by
one and two um but
um it will uh it will be maybe more
relevant uh when I'll talk about
insertion deltion codes um but the big
theorem here is due to bason G Hara
Sudan and vadan U improved by assadian
shinar recently which says that if you
allow um to to Output bot the rate
decreases kind of dramatically so we can
construct constant query relaxed ldcs
with essentially linear uh size linear
length uh and this matches uh the lower
bounds that were proved
okay um so there was a question uh that
was uh asked by gor and laes um um which
is what happens for Q equals two so this
there exists a q but we don't know it's
it's a large Q what about Q equals
2 um are there linear or almost
linears um and this is a question that
we managed to solve recently and and we
essentially prove an exponential lower
Bound for two queries so these are rlcs
with exponential uh lower bounds and I'm
I'm listing two problems here that I
think are kind of doable they're not
nothing like in the space of problems
that we see the Breakthrough type
questions um this lower bounds holds um
when um when with the definition uh that
perfect completeness uh holds for the
rldc so uh we uh we want output always
the correct bit if uh we don't have
errors um and there is this coroller
here that for some
um some
constant query complexity um the length
drops from Super polinomial to or to to
polinomial just from Q to Q + one um and
we thought uh it would be interesting to
see where this drop um
happens okay so I think I'll stop here
um yeah thanks for your
[Applause]
attention
question I have a question about the the
last point so is it clear it has to drop
one
yeah yeah so we have the exponential
lower bound at two and somewhere it's n
to the one
plus so there exists some Q not for
which so there exists some Q where it it
drops right it's a sharp transition
ESS
all right let's one more
time